are you clay I'm doing well thanks for
having me on rich you got it are you a
game of Thrones person like iron rogers
as well no I'm pretty confident I put
Aaron Rogers on the Game of Thrones yeah
you might have a picture with kid
Harrington or whatever it is but I've
got posters of Khaleesi up in my room so
that makes me just as much of a fanboy
well I got to tell you are you saying
that there's such a thing as a mother of
dragons Fathead Clay Matthews are you
really saying that to me my custom-made
custom-made just for the one and only I
put it on the ceiling so I can just look
at it before I go to sleep I think I was
just I was disappointed when they um
when they push back the release date I
get it you knows winter wherever it is
they're filming so I'm really
anticipating this season coming up yeah
I am too I'm going to try and get some
spoilers out of Jon Snow but I don't
think they're gonna be anything to be
forthcoming so but I you know you would
would you say you would be dill frackie
I mean if you could be any any character
if I gave you an opportunity to guest on
Game of Thrones what would you do would
you be now yeah Dothraki would
definitely I just don't know if I would
sit in I think I would like be more of a
white Walker you know just uh he's
really like you know you need some of
that Valyrian steel and a dragon glass
to get after me a little bit so I'd love
to be a white Walker so you know I know
you're you know everybody listens to
your show you fantastic
I'm hoping there's uh you know a
recruiting talent out that I was
listening to this and wants to make
feature me as a as a white Walker well I
think they haven't shot season eight yet
clay uh we make dreams come true here on
the show you know you well I'm gonna
hold you to this now I'm all in now but
Brocklin you have a suggestion for him
you gotta make ya clay looks more like a
wildling to me what do you think clay I
feel like I could do it all and I take
you know I take a lot of pride nuts so I
could be a wildling be a Dothraki giver
for uh a white Walker you're versatile
but that's for sure
so how how are you different now than
you were the first when you walked off
the campus at SC how are things channel
for you click I you know it's funny cuz
I was just you know now that we're
getting ready to head back to camp here
and then next week or so you have these
conversations with your family and just
can't believe I'm going in a year not
nine and I was just no it seems like
yesterday I'll you know getting drafted
and you know I have a zero idea of what
what my future had in store for me but
you know I just feel season I understand
you know what's expected not only my
role you know on this team but you know
kind of what I'm trying to accomplish as
well so you know I'm excited I know I'm
going into year nine and you know a lot
of people have had great careers in less
time but you know I still feel like I
have a lot of ball left in me and you
know I think our teams on the precipice
of always you know in being that one
team you know left at the end of the
year so I think you know big things are
in store for you know not only myself
but for the Packers as well do you think
staying inside helps you stay on the
field with in terms of just injuries
just being inside is helpful for you
clay well you know I think when they I
think just in general you know when
they're able to mix you know mix me at
inside and outside I think it just
brings a you know something that is
different in that I'm not just you know
guy they throw on the edge with Russia
pass or a play inside so you know as far
as the health is concerned you know I
took the shot last year was playing with
a separated shoulder you know getting it
shot up week in and week out and just
trying to battle through it so you know
hopefully that's an anomaly in that but
you know for the most part I think
that's what you know we're envisioning
this year as well as you know having
time on both the left and right outside
get after the quarterback playing inside
you know covering backs out of the
backfield like I said I mean much like
my Game of Thrones status as you know I
think I'm a jack-of-all-trades here so
you know I see I see them using me much
in the same light and you know
fortunately they think it's really
worked out not only for my own career
but for the Packers as well in-house
Lambeau right that's what that would be
the hell out yeah of course well you
said king of the north I thought you're
introducing me at first yeah yes then
you know maybe just Prince or something
no no it's okay
no you're not or the Lord Commander
you're I'm up for whatever you're into
there clay so Chris you got it if I
couldn't let you change a rule in the
NFL what would it be and I you know
obviously getting after quarterbacks
I mean you just get so much protection
nowadays I mean I understand not going
low deliberately and you know hands away
from the helmet but it just feels like
you can't you know get a good solid hit
without taking a you know taking a flag
or a fine the following week so
sometimes that's a little teddy you know
I realize they quarterbacks you know
they're like the homerun hitters in
baseball everybody wants to see them
they're what drive the offense up and
down the field but you know that would
be a nice change but I am glad to see
that they change the celebration rules
you know I think you know you look at
the fans watching the game I know a lot
of the old heads will be upset because
you know they just want to see teamwork
and guys celebrate with one another but
I mean you also appealing to a younger
younger demographic and wants to see you
know what uh what these uh you know
playmakers what these people who scored
touchdowns have in store for us so if
you score this year would you have
something in store or not front you know
I that's the problem because when I do
score which is hue and far between I
just like I don't know what to do
because I don't I never plan on it I
don't plan on scoring when I do I just
freak out and then after the fact I just
you know I shake my head they'll just
punt the ball in the stands I throw it
out there that's that's pretty boss
especially when you're you know I had
the opposition's field or something that
sure is good so have you done what was
the last time you did a Lambeau leap
clay Mathews I think 2010 against the
Dallas Cowboys at home I think a
Jayhawks hit the pass and I took it for
maybe 50 60 yards to the house and did a
horrible rendition of a Lambeau leap I
got halfway up got stuck teammates made
fun of me I gladly do it again now I bet
I bet so I'm wondering when I take a
look at your career 72 and a half career
sacks do you know the quarterback that
you have sacked the most I have this
information in front of me clay do you
know um the Jay Cutler it is that so are
you gonna miss Jay play listen I would
enjoy playing against Jay he you know
obviously rub some fans the wrong way I
know people get on about his nonchalant
attitude but I always enjoyed playing
against them so
I'm glad that I got a lot of facts
against him I'll miss that the most
but hopefully the next in line in
Chicago will be as equally willing to
you know help me pad my stats your neck
next up is a Christian Ponder by the way
I'll read you the list you got Alex you
got him six times he got Cutler eight
and a half who got the other half man I
would just thought you just you'd take
all the Jay down but I guess you didn't
know it as Erik Walden it was with the
Colts last year he stole half in fact I
even think as petty as I am I petitioned
the league to get that small sack they
didn't give it to me what do you mean
you put this in the league what are you
talking about you know when you get a
sack or if something happens you know
you can send it into the league for
review well with sacks it's no different
if you think you got half a sack but
it's just you got to come with the come
to terms that if you steal your
teammates have a side you're probably
not gonna be boys for the rest of the
year so you know but I was willing to
take that because there's a difference
between a three and a half sack and a
four set game and unfortunately it was
just three and a half I've got Mike
Daniels in studio tomorrow what can you
tell me about him oh oh oh my gosh well
he's going to bring high energy um you
know just make sure you have some coffee
on set for him because he's uh he's high
energy I really like him as a teammate
he you know he's still know he's in the
building before you need to introduce
himself so it should be a good interview
tomorrow
I can't wait clay Mathews a few more
minutes with him here on behalf of
Wonderful Pistachios which we will
discuss in a moment did you I'm
wondering what you think because
Terrance Knighton up was talking about
the NBA contracts that are out there and
why NFL players aren't paid like that
what do you think about the bonanza that
went down in NBA free agency claim at
all it's unbelievable I mean watching uh
watching these guys get paid as much as
they do and not only you know as much
they do but that it's fully guaranteed
all that to do is not retire and they
make all that money but you know you
like it's comparing apples and oranges
it's very much different obviously we
can sit here and say it's unfair but you
know what's unfair that I'm not four
inches six inches taller pingdong shoot
the three and dribble you know
exceptionally well or else I'd be in the
NBA so that's what's unfair is that you
know I have to play football and I can't
play basketball so that's that's the
real travesty here okay so you're doing
a kamar
doing a commercial with Richard chairman
for Wonderful Pistachios or just your
doing separate videos for them we're
doing yeah we're doing separate spots so
we're not we're not in the same one but
they're equally is fine so yeah we're on
the funnest set here with Wonderful
Pistachios filming a few uh you know
commercials for your entertainment
during this football season and you know
we obviously want to spread the word
that it's a great snack for football
fans high in protein low in calories and
you know part of my diet so you know
make sure you go and buy some wonderful
pistachios and enjoy enjoy our
commercials as well yeah because
everybody knows I make I make great
great come on you do man I mean you got
side myself you got ability clay
I mean seriously that the the creators
of Game of Thrones are being sane to not
stick you in Westeros for seasoning
they really agree they really would now
anytime I bring this up with you you
always say I was horrible to you when
you were an intern at the NFL Network is
that really true when you know I am a
very good story but I want the truth to
be you know to be had and that is that
you weren't horrible to me you just
never had time for me so in a way you
would your door would be locked and you
pick up the phone right when I'd be
knocking on the door and as if you're on
a call so you would never mean to me
it's just that I could never find out if
you were a nice guy or if you were mean
to me so but I tell you what when I
intern at NFL Network you know my job
while wasn't the most gratifying I'll
tell you what I stocks your mini fridge
like no man I mean I was a master at
Tetris and I every you know alcohol you
requested every candy bar you know
everything you had requested that was
illegal on site I would sneak it in for
you okay and then that's where your your
your affinity for pistachios probably
came from because I was all you had you
had a giant gallon size oh yeah
Wonderful Pistachios
and that's where it started much like
you know my enthusiasm for the NFL when
I worked at the network is your
pistachio collection as well okay I owe
all my success to you well let me tell
you something I am I am going to um you
know apologize because when you came to
the door and I got on the phone there
was nobody on the phone
clay yeah I mean it was just that just a
tried and true veteran move on my part
I'm gonna make it up to you though we're
going to get you on Game of Thrones
I am dead freakin serious about it I
just want I want nothing more well not
only to own a Ferrari but to all but I
think that that in itself would be
amazed I got to tell you though you
Elizabeth Banks who I'm sure you know
through that's perfect - she's probably
got some ins - so let's let's work
together to make this happen okay yeah
not like your it's not like you are
empty of Hollywood connections climb
outhouse okay oh my phone is just full
of a listers and directors Spielberg -
Bruckheimer's yeah we can we can make
this happen
and you know it's because you're so you
know you're so willing to help yes I
think maybe they should have me as like
a wildling and then you know you're kind
of on all fours the I mean I have like a
leash around here
you're real wild wild now so that way we
can get you in there as well I don't
think I've got the hair for the part
clay but maybe they can put me in makeup
for a few hours and we can make that
work well just yeah we'll just put some
cataract contacts over you look like the
old man while banks just full of insight
with clay you're the best thanks for
calling in we'll chat tuners thank you
very much you got to claim at the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience if you like some of that get
some more of that on the Rich Eisen show
app follow all the information you see
right here on the Rich Eisen show